Hey, Vsauce. Michael here. I am
distorted. The pixels you are watching have been
time displaced. They've been mapped onto a gradient
and the darker the region they're mapped to,
the further behind
they lag. The effect is really fun but it's certainly
not realistic. Or is it?
Many, many popular digital cameras suffer
from lag induced distortion,
like what you just saw, though much,
much more subtle. Usually completely
unnoticeable. It's called a rolling shutter.
Instead of snapping a full exposure at once
they quickly scan strips of each frame. It's
usually undetectable. But when the
subject changes faster than the camera
scans,
you get the famous geloey wobbly rolling
shutter effect. Really fast
things, like vibrating guitar strings and
airplane propellers,
are famous victims, but people can be too.
Luke Mandel submitted this photo
to Boing Boing[.net]. His camera scans left to
right and, in this instance,
managed to capture a blink, eyes closed
when the scan began and then open in the
reflection scanned a fraction
of a second later.
But the rolling shutter effect
is not just a neat curiosity. It represents
a fundamental and inescapable distortion that
affects everything we see. Rolling shutter
or not. First things first, let's talk about distortions.
A hallucination is a distortion of reality
when there is no apparent stimulus. If you are merely
misinterpreting an actual stimulus, that is an illusion.
But some distortions occur before our sense organs
and minds get in the way. They are called
optical phenomena. They are not the
result of sensation or perception gone wrong.
Instead, optical phenomena are distortions
caused by the mere properties of light
and matter
in and of themselves. If you look up at the sky
and see a giant vivid drinking gourd,
you are hallucinating. But if you see a flat
two-dimensional connect-the-dots
Big Dipper, you are seeing
an illusion. It's an illusion because those dots merely
appear to be on the same plane, like
holes poked in the dark roof of the sky.
In reality, those dots are stars
lightyears apart from one another in three dimensions.
As Celestron's brilliant free real-time
3D visualization of space
shows, from different perspectives, besides our own,
they look a lot less like a dipper or plough.
In fact, all constellations and asterisms
are geocentric illusions. From a wider perspective
their outlines point inward,
to the single lowly point in space
that gave them their names. But you can't blame us.
I mean, Earth is the only perspective any
human has ever had.
And even Voyager 1,
the most distant man-made object,
is still not even close to being far
enough away for the constellations to look
even remotely different than they do here on Earth.
It's also not our fault, our eyes' and brains'
fault, that distant, distant stars weren't included
in our early cosmic connect-the-dot game.
Sure, our eyesight could be better,
but optical phenomena are also to blame.
If it weren't for red shifting and the
inverse square law and light extinction,
distant things could be seen in all their glory.
The night sky would look phenomenal. Many structures
up there are huge. They're just
too dim for their hugeness to be appreciated.
When we see Hubble Telescope images of
distant objects, like the Helix Nebula,
it's easy to think that, without a telescope to zoom in,
the object must just be a tiny point in the sky.
But in reality, even though the Helix Nebula is
700 light years away, it's
3 lightyears across. If we could make the Helix Nebula
less dim, if our eyes could take a
really long exposure of it,
we would see the Helix Nebula
as it really is - nearly 70% the apparent diameter
of our Moon. This is a serious picture.
That is how large
the Helix Nebula would appear in the
night sky from Earth
if it just wasn't so dim. Our Moon is
tiny in the sky, by the way. It's easy to
think of the moon as this huge
baseball-sized thing up there in the sky,
but that's an illusion.
Try this the next time you see the
Moon. Grab a sheet of notebook paper
and you will notice that the angular
diameter of the Moon
is the same size as a hole punched in a
sheet of notebook paper held
in arms-length away. Seriously, try it
sometime. It shows just how
cute and tiny our little moon is.
The Orion Nebula
would appear even larger, if we saw all of its light.
And the Andromeda Galaxy? Just
a smudge in the sky to our eyes. But if our
eyes were better at collecting
dim light, we would see Andromeda's true extent
in our sky. Of course, our
night sky doesn't look like that. Distant objects
are dimmer, that's a bummer. But light still
wins when it comes to speed.
Light travels at the fastest speed.
In fact, in a vacuum, light travels
300,000 kilometres a second.
That's fast.
But not really. I mean, not compared to how far apart
things are in the universe. Sydney, Australia
is 1/14th of a light second away from London.
But the Andromeda Galaxy is
2,500,000 light years away from London.
To put that in perspective let's take a
light speed journey from London
to Sydney. It would look like this... Ready?
Three, two, one, go!
Nice! Alright, alright. Here's the Andromeda Galaxy.
Okay, now, relativistic effects aside,
let's take a look at what it would look
like to travel toward the Andromeda Galaxy
at the speed of light. Are you ready? Alright.
Three, two, one, go!
Yeah. I mean, seriously, it's
pretty lame. Even at the speed of light,
the fastest speed possible, a year from now
we won't even be a millionth of the way there.
That's how far away
Andromeda is. It's almost sad
in a way. But this brings us back to
the rolling shutter effect.
The Andromeda Galaxy is huge. It's more
than a hundred thousand light years across
and our view of it is tilted.
Which means that, on the plane we view it in,
light from the back
represents what Andromeda looked like
thousands and thousands of years before
what light from the front represents.
Changes in its appearance reach us
sooner from the front
than from the back. Andromeda is rotating,
spinning at hundreds of kilometers per
second in some places.
Now, a lag between light coming from near
and far points on a spinning object, results
in a skewed image. The rolling shutter
effect on a cosmic scale
applied to, say, a chessboard, seeing the front
ahead of the back is pretty trippy and dramatic.
So, does that mean we see
wobbly, funhouse mirror, rolling
shutter effect versions of Andromeda
and other distant galaxies? Well, technically
yeah, but the distortion is negligible. It may as well be
ignored. Why? Well,
the speeds used in these visualizations are not
to scale. On average, yes, matter within galaxies
orbits the galactic center at hundreds
of kilometers per second
but galaxies are so huge it takes them
hundreds of millions of years to complete just one
rotation. In other words, the lag between light
reaching you from near and far points on a galaxy,
is nothing compared to how much time it takes
matter in the galaxy to travel that same distance.
In the case of Andromeda, if you insisted
on seeing Andromeda as it really is,
that is, corrected for any lag caused by
the fact that the speed of light is
finite, the most extreme points on the Galaxy
would only need to be adjusted by about a 10,000th of
the width of any image. In this case, less than a pixel.
So, it's not a big deal. But it's not a nothing deal.
It's real. In fact, everything we look at is,
in some way, distorted by the fact that the speed of light
is finite. Your own feet are about
5 to 6 light nano seconds away from your
eyes, which means when you look at your feet
you are seeing where they were 5 to 6
nano seconds ago. 5 to 6 nanoseconds in the past.
Of course, a delay that brief is pretty
much undetectable
but it is calculate-able. If it makes you feel
a little sad to know that even with the sharpest mind
or the best instruments, appearances still depend on
where you are. That optical phenomena insure
appearances are always relative(?) Don't feel bad.
We call the people closest to us our relatives.
We're really just a family, a big family
of reference frames that,
like a family, don't always agree
but do have plenty of cool things to look at.
I'd like to thank my editor, Guy, for help with the
rolling shutter effect in this video.
And I'd like to thank you, because, as always
thanks for watching.
Oh, here's something cool.
I will be at YouTube Fan Fest with HP
in India very very soon. Check the
description for more info. If you can
make it,
I hope to see you there.